et voilà à quoi ressemble notre
administration
au pied du bâtiment touché l'homme qui
filme est un secouriste
bouleversé par l'ampleur des dégâts
la frappe russe s'est abattue à 8h01
filmé par une caméra de vidéo
surveillance
sur cette image arrêtée on distingue
clairement un missile
juste en dessous au moment de l'impact
quelques voitures tentent de prendre la
fuite
dans la panique leurs occupants roule
portière ouverte
alors qu'un épée nuage de fumée s'abat
sur la place ont distingue des
silhouettes s'extraire du bâtiment à
pied
cela s'en sortit
au sixième jour de l'offensive russe les
bombardements touchent la deuxième ville
de l'Ukraine en plein cœur le président
ukrainien a réagi
aujourd'hui les forces russes sont
brutalement tirées sur gars qui avec des
roquettes d'artillerie c'est clairement
un crime de guerre
selon les autorités sur place au moins
six corps ont été évacués mais il reste
encore des victimes sous les décombres
dans cet amas de débris une course
contre la montre commence pour retrouver
d'éventuelles survivants
le secouriste qui filme semble vouloir
prendre le monde à témoin
ça c'est pour ceux qui croyaient à la
paix avec les Russes
ce midi les rares habitants qui
s'aventurent dans les rues de carquish
semble avoir bien du mal à reconnaître
leur propre ville